hi
i'm here to interview mr pope okay come
here
thank you
hello hi can i ask you some questions
sure i'm on my way to the uh
okay
so what did you have for breakfast this
morning
uh this morning i had a pastry and
colombian coffee
how do you usually travel to school
twice a week i take the car and
three times two times a week i take a
train three times i take the car
how long is your journey to school from
door to door oh
one hour by train 30 minutes by car
what's your mindset when you enter the
school every day i think about how can i
inspire my students
name one thing you love about the area
your school is in
i love the japanese community
and who is your favorite movie star
wesley snipes
and who is your favorite singer or band
shade
who's your hero
thor
what's the one place you would love to
visit antarctica
what's your favorite subject at school
of course science and what was your
least favorite subject at school
mathematics what kind of student were
you at school
uh creative and inquisitive and what's
your favorite food in the school
cafeteria
friday pizza what time do you usually
leave school
three o'clock and you usually keep
working when you get home
if it needs me
what do you do to relax read and watch
netflix
and what are your passions or hobbies
outside teaching
i like to study capoeira study languages
and think about where to travel
and what's your proudest achievement as
a teacher
winning the presidential award for
excellence in science teaching
and if you could write one motivational
quote on your blackboard what would it
be
success requires a commitment to
i can and i will and what's the most
important advice you would give to your
students
i tell my students you need to not be
afraid to make a mistake
and to learn from those mistakes and
finally what why did you become a
teacher
i hope to inspire the next generation
and occurs in the voice of the sciences
oh okay great thank you
bye